el agua y llega a la altura del
parabrisas mayor que se sumerge en la
medida que la tormenta ayuda abre un
rastro de destrucción hacia el norte
concentró al parc registrando un nuevo
récord de tres pulgadas de lluvia en tan
solo una hora el alcalde de nueva york
bill de blasio anunció el estado de
emergencia la noche del miércoles luego
de que las calles quedaran inundadas
los conductores varados y los metros
cerrados
estamos atravesando un evento
meteorológico histórico esta noche con
lluvias de récord en toda la ciudad
inundaciones brutales y condiciones
peligrosas en nuestras carreteras
también se han emitido al menos cinco
emergencias por inundaciones repentinas
desde el oeste de filadelfia esta nueva
jersey donde se declaró otro estado de
emergencia más temprano el miércoles
antes de moverse al noreste precisamente
a nueva york- ayuda había causado
estragos en la costa sureste
la tormenta se desarrolló en el golfo de
mexico la semana pasada pasando por cuba
y tocando tierra en luisiana en eeuu en
el fin de semana como un huracán de
categoría 4 a ella se abrió paso de
golpe a través de luisiana sumergió a
nueva orleans en la oscuridad y dejó a
más de un millón de personas en el
estado sin electricidad
en misisipí hizo que un puente colapsara
y generó tornados en maryland y
pensilvania derribando postes de
electricidad y tumbando árboles la
vigilancia de tornados se ha establecido
en varias ciudades incluida conneticut
se espera que aida continúe viajando
hacia el norte trayendo fuertes lluvias
hacia la región de nueva inglaterra
esto se da luego de que la tormenta
tropical henri causar inundaciones
severas justo hace una semana dejando el
noreste del país vulnerable a los
aguaceros